und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend seitdem die stiko die ständige
impfkommission ihre empfehlung für afra
geimpfte geändert hat ist in den
hausarztpraxen wieder ordentlich was los
natürlich wollen jetzt viele patienten
schneller eine zweitimpfung und die dann
mit bayern teckstadt nochmal astra der
hausarztverband spricht heute jedenfalls
von einem enormen mehraufwand seit der
neuen empfehlung zu der kreuz impfung
riten virologen übrigens schon seit
wochen aber die stiko hat als
offizielles gremium den anspruch die
jeweiligen daten lagen besonders
gründlich zu prüfen
interessant wird sein ob sie auch ihre
empfehlung bezüglich der impfung von
kindern in den nächsten wochen noch mal
ändert dann gäbe es wohl den nächsten
ansturm auf die haus und
kinderarztpraxen sibylle bassler
berichtet christian seel und seine söhne
sander und eric sind extra aus kassel
zur impfung angereist viereinhalb
stunden hat die fahrt gedauert etwas
mulmig fühlen sie sich schon ein
bisschen macht man sich schon sorgen ist
es zugelassen ist nicht zugelassen
die stiko empfiehlt nicht wir sind
verunsichert natürlich als leiter wir
haben jetzt aber dort trotzdem gesagt
wir machen
schlange stehen vor einer neuen
arztpraxis aus ganz deutschland sind
eltern angereist um hier ihre kinder
gegen korona impfen zu lassen
ich habe hausärzte herumtelefoniert ich
habe die kinderärzte abtelefoniert ich
habe meine frauenärztin münchen
angerufen
keiner wollte kinder impfen ich habe ich
auch gesagt angst dass meine kinder
daran erkranken und sterben können ganz
ehrlich und deswegen werden
seit mitte juni hat der
allgemeinmediziner christian grüner über
300 kinder und jugendliche ab zwölf mit
bayern keck geimpft kritik daran kann er
nicht nachvollziehen denn die ständige
impfkommission in deutschland so der
mediziner rate ja nicht von der impfung
von kindern ab tatsächlich gibt es nur
keine allgemeine empfehlung für kinder
ohne vorerkrankungen dass dort so stiko
hat ganz klar gesagt man soll
ab dem zwölften lebensjahr sogar
dringend eben gerade in bezug auf die
delta variante und auch die american
heart association also die amerikanische
herzgesellschaft ganz klar dieses thema
mit den herzmuskel zahlungen des eher
vernachlässigbar weil die treten zwar
auf sind aber alle sehr mild und sehr
harmlos im verlauf in den usa wurden
bereits rund 30 millionen 12 bis 18
jährige kämpft seit mai bis mögliche
komplikationen auftreten kann es bis zu
zwei monate dauern
grund für den kinder infektiologen
johannes hübner erstmal abzuwarten
das wichtigste was wir im moment jetzt
tun können auch für die kinder ist dass
wir die erwachsenen erst mal soweit wie
möglich durch impfen ein hoher anzahl
anteil kämpfte bei den erwachsenen
schützt auch die kinder das haben wir
durch erfahrungen aus israel gesehen für
den bayerischen arzt christian kröger
ist dies allerdings keine option auf
herdenimmunität bei kindern zu setzen
sieht er problematisch finde nicht zu
dämpfen heißt wir zu solchen sie impfen
oder durch solche situation haben sie
aber da muss man auch sagen
historisch gesehen war es noch nie
schlauer sich zur infizierung als sich
impfen zu lassen
sagna und eric sind geimpft und auch ihr
vater bekommt seine dosis die
erleichterung ist groß
jetzt geht's für die drei wieder zurück
nach kassel anfang august sieht man sich
wieder zur zweitimpfung
wir wollen uns klagen hausarzt und
impfzentren darüber dass viele leute
ihre zwei termine einfach verstreichen
lassen ohne abzusagen
deshalb wird jetzt sogar die forderung
laut dafür bußgelder zu verhängen
viele andere infos zum thema impfungen
finden sie bei uns auch online auf zdf
heute tief wie angespannt das verhältnis
zwischen der nato und russland geworden
ist lässt sich aktuell über dem
schwarzen meer beobachten dort halten
mehrere europäische nato staaten
zusammen mit den usa und der ukraine das
militärmanöver seabreeze ab die brise
weht da streckenweise ziemlich steif
russische kampfjets bomber halten dort
jetzt auch sogenannte übungsflüge ab um
wie es aus dem russischen
verteidigungsministerium heißt das
westliche seemanöver zu beobachten
schon im vorfeld hatte russland ein
britisches kriegsschiff mit warnschüssen
zum kurswechsel gedrängt und niederl
angeklagt die russen hätten
scheinangriffe gegen eine ihrer
fregatten geflogen
welche rolle die bundeswehr in dieser
gemengelage spielt berichtet thomas
reichert es ist ein ausdruck dessen
donnerhall weit zu hören ist weit zu
hören sein soll
an der südgrenze der nato rumäniens
schwarzmeerküste landen
der chef der deutschen luftwaffe und der
stellvertretende chef der britischen
touchdown an brennpunkt der spannungen
zwischen russland und der nato
nach den vorfällen der letzten tage ist
es umso wichtiger dass wir hier sind wir
wollen nicht zu aggressiv sein
das dürfen wir auf keinen fall aber wir
müssen hier an der südflanke
zusammenstehen um zu zeigen genau hier
ist auch die rote linie zusammenstehen
heißt zusammen fliegen deutsche
luftraumüberwachung gemeinsam mit
rumänen und briten zum ersten mal am
schwarzen meer mit scharfen waffen und
mit der hoffnung dass die roten
liga gezogen werden sollen auch
verstanden werden vom gegenüber von
russland es ist eine anspannung
natürlich da besonders wenn die wenn der
alarm unangekündigt kommt aber wir sind
in der professionell und wir fahren
unsere verfahren habe und da ist
keinerlei angst in dem es in den spielen
der stützpunkt konstanzer liegt
gegenüber der krim 2014 von russland
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert und direkt
am schwarzen meer muss zuletzt gleich
mehrere zwischenfälle gab zwischen nato
schiffen und russischen streitkräften
russland sieht die schuld bei der nato
und bei einem von den usa und der
ukraine angeführten marinemanöver sea
breeze meeresbrise
washington und seine verbündeten sind
ständig dabei aus dem schwarzen meer das
eine region der zusammenarbeit war eine
zone der bewaffneten auseinandersetzung
zu machen
auf der luftwaffenbasis von konstanzer
klingt das ganz anders
die zeremonie auf dem rollfeld soll die
zusammenarbeit besiegeln gegen ein aus
sicht der nato immer aggressiver
russland auf flugzeuge etwa ohne
identifikation die mit manövern
provozieren die nato piloten bisher kaum
kannten absolut habe ich ein höchstes
vertrauen in meine besatzungen dass sie
in dem moment absolut ruhig bleiben und
besonnen bleiben und sich hier nicht
herausfordern lassen wir hatten diese
vorfälle auch schon den vergangenheit
und auch schon im baltikum aber wir sind
dabei immer sehr reaktive die hoffnung
ist dass das auch so bleibt dass beide
seiten die nerven bewahren wenn sie sich
hochgerüstet begegnen hier am schwarzen
meer an der südgrenze der nato und jetzt
hans wolf mit anderen nachrichten des
tages
brasiliens oberster gerichtshof lässt
ermittlungen gegen präsident bruce sohn
euro zu im zusammenhang mit mutmaßlicher
korruption bei einem impfstoff vertrag
eine gruppe von senatoren wirft personal
vor er habe einen verdacht auf
korruption ignoriert der präsident
bestreitet jedes fehlverhalten bei einer
demonstration in rio de janeiro wurde
erneut personals rücktritt gefordert
in jüngster zeit gab es mehrfach große
proteste gegen boll szenarios umgang mit
der korona pandemie die vereinten
nationen warnen vor einer
hungerkatastrophe in der äthiopischen
krisenregion tigra dort haben mehr als
400.000 menschen nicht mehr genug zu
essen so un-mitarbeiter 33.000 kinder
sind schwer unterernährt weitere 1,8
millionen menschen von hunger bedroht
integral gibt es seit monaten kämpfe
zwischen der äthiopischen armee und
regionalen rebellen hunderttausende
menschen
sind auf der flucht in japan haben
heftige regenfälle schwere
überschwemmungen und erdrutsche
ausgelöst
in der küstenstadt atami südwestlich von
tokio wollte eine schlammlawine mit 40
kilometern pro stunde durch den ort und
riss mehrere häuser mit sich mindestens
zwei menschen starben mehrere werden
noch vermisst die zahl der erdrutsche
ist in japan in den letzten jahren stark
gestiegen
experten gehen davon aus dass das eine
folge des klimawandels ist weil es mehr
regnet das jahr für jahr unfassbare
mengen von plastikmüll produziert werden
und mit welchen folgen ist altbekannt
auch deutschland gehört zu den müll
weltmeistern im schnitt produziert hier
jeder einzelne von uns jährlich 76 kilo
kunststoffabfälle davon allein 38 kilo
durch verpackungen ab heute sind in der
gesamten eu zumindest bestimmte
einwegprodukte verboten
zum beispiel wattestäbchen besteck oder
stroh engel die nach gebrauch
weggeworfen werden fragt sich ob das
genügt und wie ökologisch sinnvoll die
alternativen sind elisabeth schmidt
berichtet es sind die letzten
plastiklöffel in ihrem schrank und die
darf tanja metz inhaberin einer eisdiele
in hannover auch ganz offiziell noch auf
braucht trotzdem gut mein ziel dass man
in der eu jetzt kein neues einweg
plastikgeschirr man schaffen darf als
wir 2012 angefangen habe war ich
eigentlich geschockt dass jede kugel eis
in einem plastikbecher verkauft wird und
für mich war von anfang an klar dass
geht geht nicht das möchte ich nicht und
habe dann nach alternativen gesucht und
zwar sehr sehr schwer es gab nicht viel
auswahl auf dem markt was so
alternativen angeht
die eu machte druck allein aus den
mitgliedsstaaten landen jedes jahr bis
zu 500.000 tonnen plastik in mehr in
deutschland werden jede stunde 320.000
einwegbecher für getränke gebraucht und
weggeschmissen
jetzt werden einwegprodukte wie plastik
to go becher und geschirr verboten so
wie fast food behälter aus styropor
trinkhalme ruhe und wattestäbchen aus
plastik sind auch tabu
es ist zuallererst ein politisch
wichtiges signal dass wir zuviel einweg
plastik produzieren das zuviel von
beispielsweise ein weg plastikgeschirr
in der umwelt landet einige täter war
restaurants sind schon umgestiegen auf
alternative verpackungen aus papier glas
oder bambus doch hier kommt dann aber
von vielen umweltschützern
denn diese auf den ersten blick
möglicherweise nachhaltig anmutenden ein
weg varianten die müssen auch
energieintensiv hergestellt werden die
werden zum teil um die halbe welt
geschickt damit man hier für zehn
minuten genuss was davon runter ist und
dann ist es abfall tests von
verbraucherschutzorganisationen ergaben
außerdem nicht alle plastik alternativen
sind gesund in diesen tests fand man bei
über 50 prozent der untersuchten proben
schadstoffe oder auch pestizidrückstände
und das bedenklich ist dabei dass diese
stoffe eben wirklich unter verdacht
stehen krebserregend zu sein
tanja match wird in ihrer eisdiele auf
becher aus bio pappe sie sind für ihre
kunden gratis die essbaren eislöffel
kosten 10 cent auf jeden fall super
klasse also
wenn man das reduzieren kann sollte man
auf jeden fall keinen müll durch take
away
da will sie in ihren coffee to go
verkauft anja mez in mehrwegbehältern ab
2023 müssen restaurants und
lieferdienste in deutschland diese
behälter ihren kunden zumindest anbieten
zum sport an diesem samstag auch das
zweite halbfinale bei der fußball wm
steht fest dänemark und england werden
es bestreiten die beiden teams gewannen
am abend ihre jeweiligen
viertelfinalspiele wenn gewinner
bitterlich weinen dann ist mehr passiert
als ein branchenüblicher sieg im fußball
die emotionale reise der dänen erreicht
ihren vorläufigen höhepunkt weil thomas
lanning nach allerdings falsche eckball
entscheidung früh die führung gelingt
und kaspar dolberg noch vor der pause
auf 2 0 erhöhen kann
weder die lange anreise nach baku noch
der anschlusstreffer von tschechiens
patrick können den überraschungs
europameister von 92 auf halten stolz
nicht nur für die mannschaft aber auch
die dänische identische leute wir haben
so viele liebe getragen von der
sympathie der fans und vom eigenen
teamgeist treffen die dänen
in wembley im halbfinale auf england die
three lions besiegten im zweiten
viertelfinale des abends die ukraine mit
4 0
kapitän harry caine eröffnet das
torfestival schon in der vierten minute
direkt nach dem wechsel erhöhte auf 2 0
cain mit turnier tor nummer 3 auf 3 0
stellen kann der deutschland-bezwinger
überlegen und mit spürbarer spiellaune
das 4 0 durch jordan henderson der
endstand england als einziges team noch
ohne gegentor
jetzt geht's von rom wieder heim nach
london
beim tennisturnier in wimbledon stehen
angelique kerber und alexander zverev im
achtelfinale
kerber setzte sich gegen alexandra
sadovic aus belarus durch zverev gegen
taylor fritz aus den usa und jetzt die
lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr
59 10 18 20 49 superzahl 2 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und zdf text auf seite 55 6 die
wetteraussichten für morgen von der
ostsee bis nach ostbayern meist
freundlich sonst wechselnd bewölkt mit
teils kräftigen schauern und gewittern
lokal auch unwetter durch starkregen
möglich
höchstwerte 20 bis 28 grad die weiteren
aussichten auch in den nächsten tagen
unbeständig mit einer mischung aus sonne
wolken regengüssen und gewittern
bei höchstwerten zwischen 20 und 30 grad
das wasser uns an diesem samstagabend
weiter geht's mit der zdf-film nacht und
wir melden uns morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]